ouais New York sept est mais il
demandera environ 12 ou 11 pour un
spot de croisière les sept gagnants le sol humide et
mort vous pouvez le prendre ce mois-ci 12 au
centre-ville comment est l'un pour l'autre
cinq sessions
qu'ils écrivent je pense  à propos du gris
pour aller je pense que j'irai avec l'Ouest à
4h00 vous avez été autorisé dans le
centre-ville émoussé en avez un entrant à environ 12
oui oui base en ce moment probablement à
Brooklyn beaucoup de films pour commencer ils sont réels
facile ouais sans le gros plan d'un
véhicule qui va de quel côté
tu vas le mettre je le mettrai là juste si
nous pouvons baisser de niveau nous
devons pouvoir commander avant le
support de christos ouais c'est vraiment sympa
et puis on fera un grand angle en fait
si tu sautes à droite tu
pourras faire un bon coup un peu court oui
mais il veut faire à la fin ici
ils sont comme des buggies en retard je l'ai bien compris
de ma bouche bien commercer ou diriger la
rivière un vers le bas va plus la moitié du
pont
j'ai si tu pouvais faire ça un autre
pic grand angle ouais bon anglais
Eileen mais j'étais un peu zoomé délicatement
j'étais à UH trente quarante pour cent est
éminemment cacao arrêtez de l'enregistrer sur
une bande
Delta filait à travers celui-ci
illisible pour que les cookies du Delta du Père Noël
dix à cinq numéros à  idiot d'
abord les kilos de Monica un et demi
la dame bien sûr bon
navire à ordures je tirerais bientôt
ils ne deviennent pas aussi merdiques comme un oh je
t'ai ramené là-bas
Thunder rugit l'efficacité Les cinq de Starfleet
fonctionneront ou si au sud
de  au sommet d'une statue, enregistrez cinq
développeurs désapprouvés jusqu'à un ou
plusieurs, nous avons pris un peu ouais